[vent qui souffle]
Salut peuple des Internets !
Aujourd'hui nous entrons de le système, dans la matrice,
dans le morse en fait, on va parler de code morse.
Je ne sais pas si vous vous y êtes déjà interessé au code morse,
mais forcément comme tous les trucs un peu secrets,
et tous les trucs à comprendre,
je m'y suis interessé à un moment donné de ma vie.
Et j'ai même cherché recemment comment on pouvait apprendre le code morse.
Donc le code morse, pour ceux vraiment qui ne connaissent pas,
ce sont que des sons courts ou rapides,
Donc ça fait *Bip* ou *Biiip*,
donc c'est-à-dire que le "Biiip" est 3 fois plus long que le "Bip",
et il y a aussi un petit espace entre chaque code de lettres.
Exemple concret: le "E", c'est un *Bip" bref (court),
et le "T", c'est un *Biiip* long.
Le "S" c'est 3 *Bip* courts: "Bip-Bip-Bip"
Le "O" c'est 3 *Bip* longs: "Biiip-Biiip-Biiip"
Ce qui nous donne pour "SOS":
...  _ _ _  ...
Voilà...
Vous êtes encore là ?!
C'est interessant.
Donc c'est un code qui a été énormément utilisé par l'armée et encore utilisée à ce jour.
Et forcément les militaires apprennent ce code.
Alors attention !
Loin de moi, l'idée de faire une blague du style:
"Si des militaires peuvent l'apprendre par coeur, on doit être nous aussi capables de l'apprendre..."
Parce que ce ne serait pas bien comme blague.
Et je ne le pense pas du tout en plus.
Je me suis demandé quel était leur processus d'apprentissage...
Parce que moi, vraiment, basiquement,
pour apprendre du morse,
Je me serai dit: ok je vais faire quelque chose dans l'imagination,
pour avoir ça de standarisé dans mon esprit
et savoir si on me dit le A, je sais que c'est : bref puis long derrière.
Bref, du stockage de données, une espèce de data avec tous les symboles et la correspondance.
Mais, ce n'est pas si simple que ça pour le traduire en temps réel d'exécution.
Donc j'ai regardé des vidéos de l'armée, je vous mets un lien dans la description,
sur leur système d'apprentissage
qui en fait est assez interessant parce qu'il est synéstésique.
C'est-à-dire qu'on apprend à la fois le code brut,
on sait que long est bref, par exemple c'est le N,
mais en même temps on apprend à le reconnaitre à l'oreille et à le traduire,
donc il y a la mémoire auditive avec toute la compréhension et la mémoire visuelle qui se mettent en marche en même temps.
Et j'ai fait des exercices que je vous mets dans la description.
A savoir de noter ce que j'entendais, et au départ on note vraiment des traits et des points,
et au fur et à mesure, mais assez rapidement,
on s'aperçoit que l'on note des lettres.
Donc on est sur une traduction instantanée.
Du coup, j'ai fait des recherches,
et je pense sincèrement qu'il n'y a pas de meilleure méthode d'apprentissage du morse,
que la méthode qu'utilise les militaires.
Du coup je n'avais pas de quoi en faire une vidéo, c'est pour ça que je vous en parle aujourd'hui juste comme ça.
Je ne vais pas faire une vidéo sur quelque chose qui existe déjà,
et qui est plus performant qu'une méthode que j'aurai pu trouver.
Mais ça me permet de vous parler d'un bouquin que j'ai bien aimé.
Qui est sorti il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça.
Et attention comme d'habitude ce n'est pas un placement de produit,
c'est acheté avec mes petits sous.
Et c'est pour ça que je ne le fais pas gagné parce que je le garde.
Ca s'appelle: "Fous de codes secrets".
C'est un très bon livre,
qui est édité chez Flammarion
et à l'intérieur de ce livre, il y a 50 codes secrets qui sont repris, décryptés, expliqués.
Et en plus de ça, il y a pas mal de choses en plus du style:
l'historique des codes secrets.
Parce que ce qui est interessant c'est le contexte.
Il y a des chapitres entiers qui sont consacrés au décrypteurs célèbres comme Turing par exemple le plus célèbre d'entre eux.
Avec toute leur histoire, les anecdotes à l'intérieur.
C'est assez imagé.
C'est assez bien expliqué.
J'ai l'impression d'être une youtubeuse beauté là les gars.
Mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Si vous voulez un petit bouquin, léger à lire et référentiel des 50 principaux codes secrets,
c'est celui que je vous recommande.
J'en ai d'autres qui sont plus lourds, plus complexes,
donc aussi plus intéressants et plus poussés,
mais ce n'est pas forcément ce qu'on cherche quand on veut avoir une vision compète des codes secrets.
Je vous le dis, l'année prochaine, je vais recréer une énigme.
Et mon énigme sera basée sur les codes secrets que j'aurai réexploité de ce bouquin là.
Donc voilà à quoi peut servir un bouquin comme ça,
ou juste en culture générale.
Il est plutôt léger et fun à lire.
Lien dans la description bien sûr !
Il y a également à la fin un chapitre qui est consacré à l'avenir des codes secrets
et là je trouvais ça interessant, parce qu'on parle toujours des anciens et rarement des nouveaux.
Qui est la cryptographie quantique.
Et je ne vous en dis pas plus, vous trouverez ça là dedans, si jamais c'est un sujet qui vous interesse.
Comme d'habitude, pensez à liker la vidéo et à vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait !
N'hésitez pas à explorer l'espace description du commentaire où vous trouverez aussi en autres idées de Noel:
des places pour l'Olympia, mon livre, mon jeu, ce que tu veux, toi même tu sais.
Je te laisse t'embrasser toi-même parce que je n'ai pas le temps de faire des bises à tous ceux qui regarderons cette vidéo.
Mais rendez-vous demain à 6H du matin !
Pour la 5ème ouverture de ce calendrier de l'Avent du Mental Vlog, je ne sais pas quoi, de toi même tu sais !
Ciao !
[musique]